[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم قدم وزير الدفاع في الحكومه
السوريه المؤقته اسعد مصطفى استقالته من
منصبه احتجاجا على الاوضاع التي تمر بها
الثوره السوريه وعلى قياده المعارضه عن
قيام بواجبها تجاه المقاتلين على الارض
نتوقف مع هذا الخبر لكي نناقشه في محورين
ما وجهه الاسباب التي قدمها الاسعد لتبرير
استقالته في هذا الظرف الدقيق من عمر
الثوره السوريه والى اي حد تستطيع قياده
المعارضه السوريه تلافي المشكلات التي
حوتها صحيفه استقاله
الوزير في ظرف شديد الدقه والتعقيد من عمر
ل الثوره السوريه دفع وزير الدفاع في
الحكومه السوريه المؤقته اسعد مصطفى
باستقالته الى قياده الائتلاف الوطني
المعارض عبر رئيس حكومته من دون ان يقفل
رصد المشكلات والمعوقات التي قال انها
دفعته الى اتخاذ تلك الخطوه ورغم ان مصطفى
اكد ان الاستقاله لا تعني باي حال قطيعه
مع الثوره او الائتلاف الوطني الا انه كشف
عن عدم رضاه عن اداء قياده المعارضه خصوصا
في يتصل بواجباتها نحو المقاتلين على
الارض العسكريه حول رساله استقاله قاسيه
هي تلك التي وجهها اسعد مصطفى وزير دفاع
الحكومه السوريه المؤقته لرئيس الائتلاف
الوطني المعارض الرجل كما قال لا يريد ان
يكون شاهد زور على ما سماه استمرار تدمير
سوريا لا يريد ان يكون غطاء للفرقه بين
تشكيلات الجيش الحر النظام
يخ الله اكبر يقدم صوره قاتمه للاوضاع على
الارض ففي مواجهه نظام يزوده حلفاؤه بسيل
مستمر من السلاح والمال والرجال على حد
وصفه قاتلت وحدات الجيش الحر وقدمت مئات
الاف الشهداء واضعافه من الجرحى لينتهي
الامر بهم وقد منعت عنهم حتى وسائل
الدفاع الله
اكبر اكثر من ذلك يتحدث الرجل بمراره عما
سماه غياب جسور الحوار بين قياده الائتلاف
والتشكيلات المقاتله على نحو يوحد صفوفها
يرمي الرجل الكره في مرمى قياده الائتلاف
المعارض مشيرا الى انه لم توفر لوزارته
ايه امكانيه للقيام بالحد الادنى لتلبيه
مستلزمات الثوار الواجبه التنفيذ فورا
والحال هذه لا مفر من
الاستقاله لا يكتفي اسعد مصطفى بهذا بل
يعترف بان حدث في حمص وقد حصرت وفي الغوطه
وحلب وبقيه مدن البلاد تتحمل قياده
المعارضه مسؤوليته بالدرجه الاولى تشخيص
بالغ القسوه والواقعيه في ان ورد متفرقا
على لسان كثيرين من معارض الاسد مصدر في
الائتلاف المعارض عز استقاله مصطفى لاسباب
اخرى لكن ايا كانت الاسباب فانها تؤشر الى
ماات الثوره بعد ثلاث سنوات اكثر من 160
ال قتلوا الاف اخرون مفقودون نحو نصف سكان
البلاد اصبح ما بين نازح ولاجئ في اسوا
كارثه نزوح في العالم المعاصر منذ سنوات
وقوات الاسد تتقدم على الارض بعد ان انسحب
مقاتلون المعارضه من حمص ثالث اكبر مدينه
في البلاد اما الاسد نفسه
فمقلة اسطنبول الدكتور محمد دندل عضو
الائتلاف الوطني السوري ومن عمان العميد
اسعد الزعبي الخبير في الشؤون العسكريه
والاستراتيجيه وعبر الهاتف من الكويت اسعد
مصطفى وزير الدفاع المستقيل من الحكومه
السوريه المؤقته ابدا معك دكتور اسعد
مصطفى بالاضافه الى ما ذكرته
في نص
استقالتك اسالك الان من يتحمل مسؤوليه هذه
الاستقاله دعيني اقول لك انا لا القي ال
ال كره في ملعب احد انا
اي يعني اتحمل مسؤوليتي بالكامل اريد ان
اقول بصراحه
ا ان وزاره الدفاع اننا في وزاره الدفاع
لم نستطع ان نقدم للثوار الحد الادنى او
ما دون الحد الا لم نقدم لهم ما يجب ان
نقوم به كوزار دفاع مسؤوله ومنيه بالدرجه
الاولى عن قياده المعارك على الارض وعن
تقديم
مستلزماتها على مدى الشهور
الماضيه سوريا تدمر بكاملها
وتقصف يوميا ونحن
نتفرج لا يجوز ان ان ان نحارب نحن في في
الخارج سواء في في كل المؤسسات بالكلام
فقط المعادله
يعني يعني مكسوره فظيعه كما اوردت النظام
يرده كل انواع الاسلحه
النظام الذي يجب ان يقطع عنه السلاح لانه
مجرم يقتل الشعب السوري طيب هذا كله معروف
بالنسبه للنظام لا اسالك عن الموقف من
النظام موقف من النظام اصبح
معروفا اسالك عن الموقف من الائتلاف من
تلوم في الائتلاف القياده احمد الجربه
تلوم الدول التي تدعم احمد
الجربه تلوم الخلافات التي وقعت بان اقاله
سليم ادريس حدد لي اين كانت المشكله الان
لا ليس كل هذا ارجو ان لا تضعوا الامور في
زوايا يعني جزئيه وصغيره انا نعم الوم
اصدقاء
سوريا الذين يعدوننا بالدعم ونحن نقتل
امامهم كل يوم الامر لا يمكن احتماله انا
كوزير للدفاع لا استطيع ان اكون في هذا
المكان وان اقول للثوار سوف ياتي الدعم
وسوف ياتي وهو الدعم الحقيقي السلاح
الفعال الذي يوقف قصف البراميل وقصف
الطائرات انا لا استطيع ان يعني انا اردت
ان اقدم استقالتي يوم خروج الابطال من حمص
حمص يعني حوصرت 700 يوم ونحن لم نقدم لهم
شيء لا يستطيع احد ان يقول اننا اعددنا
خطه واننا وفرنا مستلزماتها واننا بادرنا
هذا لم
يحدث عندما لا يحدث ذلك الثوار صمدوا
النظام لم يستطع دخول حمص ولا يستطيع دخول
اطلاق لكن خرجها هؤلاء الابطال لاننا لم
نستطع فك الحصار عن حمص قلت في
استقالتك يق يوم الجمعه قلت في
استقالتك تفرض علي الامانه سيد مصطفى حتى
حتى نفهم
الاسباب
حتفهم يقد الكل يلوم الكل لست وحدك من
يلوم هؤلاء من تسمونهم الاصدقاء بانهم لم
يسلح بما يكفي الكل يلوم هؤلاء اصدقاء لكن
الكل لم يقدم استقالته مثلك انا اريد ان
اعرف انت شخصيا لماذا استقلت اذا اذا سردت
لنا هذين
السببين مساله الاصدقاء ومساله النظام
الكل لديهم ه هذان السببان ولكنهم لم
يستقيلوا مثلك انت لماذا استقلت لماذا
اخترت
الاستقاله اخترت الاستقاله لانني في موقعي
لا اقدم ما علي ان اقدمه
للثوار الثوار عندما يحتاج يتجهون لوزاره
الدفاع وزاره الدفاع ليس لديها امكانات لا
هي ولا قياده الاركان محجوب عنها كل شيء
انا لا استطيع ان اكون في مكان ولا يؤدي
هذا المكان من حجب عنه هذا المكان
صلاحياته لقد صبرت من المسؤول عن الحجب من
المسؤول عن
الحجب لا يصلنا شيء المسؤول انا قلت لك
وزاره الدفاع كان يجب ان توضع بديها كل
الامكانات التي تستطيع من خلالها تحقيق
ثلاث مسائل اولا توحيد القوه المقات على
الارض او او التنسيق بينها على الاقل
الشيء الثاني قياده عمليات عسكريه
استراتيجيه كبيره تؤدي الى اسقاط النظام
وهذا متاح الثوار على الارض يقدمون بطولات
هائله لكن المطلوب التنسيق بين بينهم في
اطار واسع الشيء الثالث ان ان تقدم لهم
المستلزمات
السلاح دعني اتوقف مع ضيفي ضيفي دكتور مح
دندل انت مستشار لرئيس الائتلاف احمد
الجربه ضيفنا من اسطنبول كثرت الشائعات
ربما او حتى انباء لا ادري مدى صحتها عن
اسباب هذه الاستقاله البعض عزاها الى خلاف
مع الجربه بسبب طعمه كل هذه الانباء ما
مدى
صحتها التي تخص يعني الخلاف مع
جربه يعني فيما يتعلق باسباب الاستقاله
السيد وزير الدفاع اوضح ال النقاط
الاساسيه التي كانت سبب استقالته كل ما
يحكى عن ان هذه الاستقاله او غيرها من
الاستقالات هي كانت بسبب خلافات مع رئيس
الائتلاف او او رئيس الحكومه يعني هنا
يعني يكون عم يقوم بتضخيم الامور بشكل
كبير انا لا لا انكر ان هناك خلاف بوجهات
النظر بين الائتلاف احيانا والحكومه او
الحكومه او رئيس الحكومه بعض الوزراء لكن
كل ذلك ناتج عن عن قله الامكانيات الحكومه
منذ انشائها لم يقدم لها سوى المنحه التي
القطريه مشكوره دوله قطر قدمت 50 مليون
يورو وهذه ال 50 مليون يورو وزعت على 12
وزاره لخطه لمده سته شهور ولم يقدم اي احد
من اصدقاء سوريا على اي مساعدات على
الاطلاق يعني لا يمكن
تخيل تعود
س تعيد سرد ما يعني يشكو منه سيد اسعد
مصطفى ولذلك قدم استقالته وهو شح
المساعدات لا سما التسليح المعتبر لماذا
لا يستقل اذا الجاره على هذه القاعده اذا
كان الكل سوف يشكو من هذا السبب الكل يشكو
من فليستقل الكل
اذا يعني لا يعني اذا كان هناك سبب
للاستقاله دفع احد ما الى تقديم استقالته
لا يعني ان الاخرين سوف يقومون بالاستقاله
لنفس الاسباب رغم ان هذه الاسباب منطقيه
ونحن يعني نؤكد على ان هذه الاسباب
صحيحه بالاساس مبدا الاستقاله كنا نتمنى
الاخ السيد اسعد مصطفى ان لا يقدم
استقالته في هذه المرحله الحرجه ونحن نعرف
ان
انص دكتور صحيح هذا الكلام كنتم تتمنون
تمنيتم سابقا اعطى فرصه ثم قال لم تكن
يعني لم يتغير شيء وبالتالي عاد واستقال
يعني هذه ليست الاست
الاولى تماما هو هو مساله الفرصه هو انا
اعتبر هذه الاستقاله هي صرخه صرخه
احتجاج للاشقاء والداعمين جميعا لان هناك
ما امور تصل على
الارض يعني بالنسبه لوزاره الدفاع وزاره
الدفاع بحاجه لمبلغ يوميا لا يقل عن 10
مليون دولار حتى تقوم بواجباتها تجاه
الكتائب ما بالك اذا اذا كل ما لحه هو بحد
7 مليون د على مده شهور هذا لا يكفي وزاره
الدفاع لشهر واحد فبالتالي هناك اسباب
منطقيه وحقيقيه تجعل كل شخص يتصدى لمنصب
وزير الدفاع ان يواجه مسؤوليات وص مليون
دولار كل يوم عفوا 10 مليون دولار الرقم
فقط على الاقل
يعني مليون دول كل كل يوم يعني
اداره عشرات الالاف ل ل تقديم الدام
اللوجستي والاطعام والى اخر ما هنالك
عشرات الالاف من المقاتلين هذا اقل عميد
اسعد الزعبي ما رايك بتوقيت الاستقاله في
في عمر الثوره الان وما يجري على
الارض بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم مساء الخير
بدايه وبكل المحبه والتقدير للسيد اسعد
مصطفى اقول وباختصار شديد ان توقيت هذه
الاستقاله هو غير مناسب تماما مع احترامي
لكل للاسباب التي كانت معلنه او غير معلنه
باسباب بديهيه جدا اذا كانت الاسباب تتعلق
بكميه او توفير الدعم او عدم توفير الدعم
ما زال الشعب السوري ومنذ بدايه الثوره
يعول على وصول دعما من الدول التي تدعي
انها اصدقاء سوريه ولكن مع الاسف الشديد
لم يصلنا دعما الا من الدول الاشقاء الدول
الخليجيه اضافه الى الاردن وتركيا
وبالتالي هذا ليس جديد على ما يتعلق بقضيه
الدعم واذا كانت الامور تتعلق بخلافات
شخصيه وانا لا ارى ذلك تماما فارى ان
الخلافات الشخصيه يجب ان توضع في برميل
ماء بارد حيال ما يتعرض له الشعب السوري
من دمار وقتل في كل يوم ولذلك لا هناك
هناك لا اسباب يعني يعني لا اسباب حقيقه
حقيقيه وراء هذه الاستقاله او مما دفع
الاخ اسعد مصطفى الى الاستقاله من المفترض
يعني هذا التف عميد ولكن اليس هنالك وجاهه
خاصه انه قال في نص استقالته بالحرف لم في
هذا الوقت كلي لم يتوفر لوزاره الدفاع اي
امكانيه للقيام بالحد الادنى من واجباتها
لتلبيه مستلزم مات الثوار على الاقل هو
يرضي ضميره بهذه
الاستقاله لا شك ان جهده مبذول التي بذلها
مشكورا عليها الحقيقه انه قام بالعديد من
الزيارات الى الداخل وبذل العديد من جهوده
لاسعاف مدينه حمص لاسعاف العديد من الثوار
بالامكانيات المتاحه المتوفره ولكن نحن
نقول ليس بالامكان افضل من مكان ولذلك
اقول مع حبي وتقديري لجهود الاخ اس السيد
اسعد مصطفى ودوره الذي قام به في وزاره
الدفاع لكن هذا لا يعني اطلاقا سماح له
بالاستقاله لان الاستقاله الحقيقه يعني لا
معنى لها في هذا الظرف بالذات يعني هناك
محطات غير طبيعيه وغير مقبوله تماما في في
المسيره السياسيه للثوره اهمها في استقاله
السيد معاذ الخطيب قبل مؤتمر دوحا وثم
تلاها استقاله المجلس الوطني قبل مؤتمر
جنيف ثم تلاها تغيير الاركان وتغيير وزاره
الدفاع قبل الموافقه على ان تقوم الدول
الصديقه ثم هذه الاستقاله ايضا نحن الان
في ظرف عسكري وسياسي صعب للغايه وب هناك
اقبال لهذا له هذا النظام بقول وقاحه على
ترشيح نفس الانتخابات اذا نحن الان لسنا
بحاجه الى فتح ثغره او فتح باب على
الاختلافات وبالتالي نحن يجب ان نكون يدا
واحده بغض النظر عن الاسباب الاسباب التي
ذكرها السيد اسم وصنا ليست ليست جديده هي
قديمه ربما تجددت او ربما تجدد القالب
الخارجي لها لكن المساعدات لم تكن في يوم
من الايام هي تكفي او هي الطلب الذي كان
يعني يعمل عليه الثوار او يطلبه الداخل
هناك اس يعني هذه الاسباب ما زالت قائمه
منذ ثلاث سنوات طيب ساعد اليكم ضيوفي
الكرام ولكن نتوقف قبل ذلك مع فاصل قصير
نناقش بعده مدى قدره قياده المعارضه
السوريه على التعامل مع المشكلات التي
اوردها وزير الدفاع لتبرير استقالته نرجو
ان تبقوا
معنا اهلا بكم من جديد سيد اسعد مصطفى
اريد ان استفسر منك اكثر عن نص استقالتك
ورد فيها انه منعت عنهم وسائل منعت عن
الثوار وسائل الدفاع المشروعه عن النفس
و وفي مقابل المنع ايضا كان هنالك منع
ايضا لمد جسور الحوار مع تشكيلات الجيش
الحر طيب فهمنا ان الاصدقاء سوريا من
تسمونه اصدقاء سوريا منعوا التسليح وال
وسائل الدفاع يعني عن النفس من منع الحوار
بين مختلف التشكيلات المسلحه على
الارض يعني ارجوك يعني يعني بكل احترام
وتق ير لا يسير الامر باتجاه
صغير انا اولا لست على خلاف مع قياده
الائتلاف ولا مع قياده الحكومه وبكل تواضع
يعني انا هذه الامور بالنسبه لي يعني
اعتقد انني اكبر منها وانا قلت للاخوه اذا
احد من المعارضه
يعني مهما فعل انا لا ارد على احد ولا
اهاجم احد وهذا معروف هذا بالنسبه لي
قناعه طيب هذا حقك استاذ مصطى ارجوك اعطي
حق
ط يفهم اكثر
المضل الشيء الذي تحدثت عنه انا اتفهم ما
قاله الاخوين الفاضلين وزاره الدفاع هي
العنوان الذي يجب ان يتجه اليه الثوار
لتلبيت مطالبهم عندما تكون امكانيات وزاره
الدفاع صفر انا لا لا يجوز ان اوهم الثوار
ان هناك وزاره دفاع ونحن في قياده الارك
وليس لدينا ما نقدمه
لهم نحن نتلقى في في اليوم مئات
الطلبات وهناك اوضاع كبيره وماسا ويه
الامر اكبر بكثير من ان انا اعدهم وان
اقول لهم نعم كما قال الاخوه هذا الامر
قديم ولكن نحن في السنه الرابعه لا يجوز
لي ان اتاقلم معه وان اكون غطاء له وان
اوهم الناس يجب ان ان نقف هنا
يجب كفى لتدمير
سوريا نقول اخو يجب ان نرفع صوتنا بشكل
عالي و ومحبه
وب تق هذه المذ
هذا هذا طيب اسمح لي فقط ان اطرح سؤالا لو
سمحت لي كيف افهم كيف نفهم كيف نفهم كانت
الامور صغيره ام كبيره وان كنت سترد ام لا
ان لم اطرح الاسئله عليك يعني انا اطرح
وانت حر بالاجابه ام لا لكن دعني اطرح لو
سمحت لي حتى نفهم اكثر اسبابك ان كانت
كبيره كما تقول واكبر مما لك ان تجيبني عن
الاسئله حكي الكثير عن هذه الاستقاله وقبل
عن الاقال استقاله سابقه هل الان الاسباب
مختلفه عن الاستقاله الاولى وما حكي عن
خلاف مع الجربه بسبب انك تريد ان تجلس
مكان طعمك كل هذه الانباء لا صحه لها وعن
خلافات على مساله انك اردت مبالغ من
الائتلاف كل هذه هل فندها لنا ورددت عليها
يا اختي حرام هذا الكلام والله اقسم لك ان
ما تقولينه يعني انا والله اموت كل يوم
انا انفجر لانني لا استطيع ان البي حاجه
الثوار حول حلب انا يعني لست بهذا الوارد
الذي تتحدثين عنه انا مستعد ان اعمل
مستشار عند عند اي احد من الائتلاف واند
اي شخص انا جندي كنت اعمل متطوع في
الاداره المحليه لا اجلس محل احد وهذا
الامر فيه يعني تصرير للمساله ارجوك انا
قلت لك تماما يعني السبب والسبب الثاني ان
هناك الان يعني انا جئت ولدي ثلاث لدي
مشروع اريد ان
اوحد الوحدات المق اللي في اطار واحد وان
يكون هناك هيكل للجيش هذا لم استطع ان
افعله ولكن استذ مصطفى شكرا على التوضيح
واقدر اقدر وقتك وصراحتك معنا سي
م الان عند عندما عندما لا اقدم للناس شي
عندما هذه الفكره هذه الفكره استوعبها
وصلت انك عندما تجد انك لا تستطيع تقديم
شيء تفضل الاستقاله لكن اريد رد سريع ايضا
قبل ان ينتهي الوقت على مساله لاموك انه
صحيح معك حق بك كل الاسباب التي سردتها
لكن الان الظرف لا يحتمل استقاله جديده
كيف ترد بسرعه على هذه النقطه لاني الوقت
داهمنا وشكرا على صراحتك بالعكس بالعكس اي
ظرف اي ظرف الظرف الان يجب يعني عندما
نقول نحن موجودين في في امكنه معطله لا
يجوز ان نبقى في مكان معطل يا اختي يجب ان
نقول بصراحه هذا الامر يجب ان يفعل ويجب
نفسح المجال لمن ياتي بعدي ان ان يلتفت
اليه الناس وان يقدمون له المساله اكبر
مني ومن ومن فل وفلان يجب ان نؤمن
احتياجات الناس على الارض يحتم مع الان
يجب ان نقول بصراح الامور وان نسميها
جزيلا ليس بجاه زيد او عبيد نحن هناك واقع
يجب ان يتوقف ويجب ان تتوقف هه جز لك
اوضحت لنا اسباب استقالتك عبر الهاتف من
الكويت اسعد مصطفى وزير الدفاع المستقل من
الحكومه السوريه المق شكرا جزيلا لك والى
ضيفي من اسطنبول دكتور الدندل اذا سيد
اسعد مصطفى يقول القصه اكبر بكث كثير من
اسباب او اتهامات او خلافات القصه دم سوري
هو لا يستطيع ان يتحمله طالما لا يستطيع
تقديم المساعده في هذا المنصب ف فالاولى
ان
يستقيل يعني الماخذ على الاخ السيد اسعد
مصطفى فيما يتعلق بالاستقاله عندما تم
تكلفه بوزاره الدفاع كان معروف ان هنا ان
الحكومه ليس لديها امكانيات كب
ولولا حقيقه لولا المنحه من دوله قطر
الشقيقه لكانت الامور اسو من ذلك بكثير
فيجب على كل من يتصدى لمنصب بالوزاره او
بالائتلاف ان يدرك ان نحن اننا نحن نواجه
ظروف صعبه وغير طبيعيه على الاطلاق وبناء
على ذلك دكتور كما اشار سيد اسعد مصطفى
يعني اشار وكانه المح اليكم هذه الرساله
او اوصل هذه الرساله بانه طيب انا استقلت
على الاقل من ياتي بعدي ربما يتعلم الدرس
وانتم تتعلمون الدرس ويكون انجع للوزاره
لهذه الوزاره مسمى وزاره الفاع في الحكومه
المؤقته ما
رايك يا سيدتي المساله يعني نحن
نتفهم والاسباب التي ساق سيد م سيد اسعد
مصطفى هي منطقيه وحقيقيه فيما يتعلق
بتقصير الاصدقاء
لكن عندما يتم التركيز على مساله عدم
القدره على على تقديم المساعده للاخوه
الثوار هذا حقيق
لكنه قد يوحي ان هناك ضمن المعارضه من
يمنع عن وزاره الدفاع او وزاره اخرى ما
يعني امكانيات لتقديم هذه المساعدات
الائتلاف وجميع المعارضه امكانياتهم
متواضعه سواء على المستوى المادي او حتى
على مستوى التسليح الائتلاف لا يمتلك
السلاح النوعي ويمنعهم وزاره الدفاعون
الثوار ولا يمتلك المال نحن لا ننكر اننا
بحاجه لدعم الاصدقاء لان ما يحدث بسوريا
هو مسؤوليه عربيه ود للامانه هو هو دكتور
للامانه السيد اسعد مصطفى كان حريصا ان
يقول لست على عداء والعلاء على خلاف مع
احد والامور اكبر من ذلك وانا اتعالى ولا
ارد على اي اتهامات لم يقول فلان او فلان
مناع التسليح هو حكى بشكل كبير يعني عنوان
عريض لصالح الشعب السوري فقط للامانه اردت
ان اق لانه لم يعد معنا عميد اسعد الزعبي
الى اي حد تستطيع اذا قياده المعارضه
السوريه تلافي المشكلات التي ادرجها في
سياق نص استقال السيد اسعد مصطفى خصوصا
انها متهمه انها الان باتت تفتقر الى
الصدقيه والقدره وتتلاعب بها الجهات
الاقليميه التي
تمولها اختي الكريمه السبب الرئيسي الذي
يعني تلاه السيد اسعد مصطفى يتعلق بتوفير
الامكانيات الماديه والعسكريه وهذه
الحقيقه منذ ثلاث سنوات ما زال الثوار في
الداخل يعني يشكون تماما من قله المساعدات
العسكريه والماديه ولكن من كان في وزاره
الدفاع بغض النظر عن الشخص كيف نقرا هي هل
يوجد مساعدات ماديه او عسكريه تليق او ح
حسب الحاجه او المتطلب ام لا كيف نقرا ذلك
عسكريا في الداخل الان يجب ان نعترف تماما
ان هناك تقدم للثوار في حلب وتقدم للثوار
في ادلب واعتقد على شاشتكم الكريمه وكل
الشاشات التي تعتني بالثوره السوريه و
وتضع العديد من الوثاق والروابط عليها
تعلم تماما ماذا حقق الثوار الان في في
الايام الاخيره في ادلب وحماه وحلب فكيف
اذا ولكن حلب في حاله يرثى لها حلب في
حاله يرثى لها هنالك تراجع في ريف دمشق
هنالك تراجع في
درعا اين التراجع في درعا اختي الكريمه
اذا جميع ال التلال المحيطه في القنيطره
ودرعا بالكامل تحررت والان النظام دفع
بقوات النخبه ونخبه النخبه من اجل ان
يحاول استعيد استعاده احد هذه التلال وما
زال يدفع العديد وبالمناسبه هناك مسجل
لدينا 317 فطيسه في النظام في منطقه نوا
فقط ما بين نوا واخ ارجو انا اب
اصلا الموضوع الميدان ليس موضوع لا تجبني
عن قدره المعارضه على تلافي هذه المشكلات
وخاصه وان يعني دول اقليميه وامريكا
وتركيا هذه الدول هي في الاخر تملك مفتاح
السلاح ومفتاح السياسه دخل الا الان الان
هناك الان هناك فرصه ثمينه امام الائتلاف
ما يجب ان يطبه الائتلاف من الدول الصديقه
للشعب السوري هو ان توقف القتل في سوريا
ان توقف رمي البراميل واستخدام الكلور
وكذلك الاسلحه الفتاكه هذا ما يجب ان
تفعله الائتلاف والقياده السياسيه في
الخارج تحدثت عن مسؤوليه الدول لم تحدث عن
مسؤ كان السؤال عن الائتلاف ربما في حلقه
اخرى شكرا جزيلا لك عميد اسعد زعبي الخبير
في الشؤون العسكريه واستراتيجيه واشكر
اشكر دكتور محمد دندل عضو الائتلاف الوطني
من اسطنبول واشكر متابعتكم بهذا تنتهي هذه
الحلقه من برنامج ما وراء الخبر نلتقي
باذن الله في قراءه جديده فيما وراء خبر
جديد الى
اللقاء
[موسيقى]
ه